now let's go and bring you the very
latest on the Oakland A's and their move
to Las Vegas their potential move here
the ballpark Bill we've been waiting to
see introduced in the legislature now in
the middle of a political Showdown a
news now investigator Kyle Payne here in
studio to explain more Kyle Brian the
Republican governor and the Democratic
Leadership went right after each other
today over the budget and the ballpark
time is running out on the legislature
session up in Carson City which ends
June 5th they currently haven't agreed
on a budget or on a plan to finance the
A's move here from Oakland sources tell
us the A's won Clark County and the
state to Pony up about 300 million
dollars in public funds and tax credits
but today the Democratic Leadership said
Point Blank they won't give the the deal
a green light if the governor doesn't
sign their budget
I think it's really hard probably to the
speaker's point if if not it's difficult
if it's an impossible right let's say
here's what we're going to approve for a
tax strategy we don't even have a budget
because we're not really sure where that
stands the governor lashed back
threatening again to veto the budget if
his priorities aren't addressed saying
quote if they choose to test me my
resolve I'll make it easy for them the
people in Nevada hired me to protect
their interests and that is what I
intend to do so far they have not taken
up or voted on any of the governor's
bills also news for Major League
Baseball today commissioner Rob Manfred
said the league could vote on the teams
move in just a couple of weeks at their
meetings in New York